[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno buenos días mi nombre es alejandra
reich
soy basura o logo de oficio si vas
uróloga me animo a decir que para mí la
basura no existe porque a mí la basura
me transformo me dio la posibilidad de
ser alguien con algo que a nadie le
importaba que todos suponen que es de
otro que el problema es de otro que el
olor es de otro que la basura es de otro
corría el año 2001 y yo trabajaba en el
microcentro en la argentina vivíamos una
situación económica muy complicada creo
que todos ustedes no se acuerdan porque
son muy jóvenes pero los que si la
pasamos complicado yo tomaba el tren en
la estación de villa por redone para ir
hasta el microcentro y cada tanto voy a
pasar otro tren un tren sin puertas sin
ventanas sin vidrios sin asientos sin
luz conocido como el tren blanco o el
tren cartonero
este tren venía del conurbano profundo
de la provincia de buenos aires- y traía
un montón de personas que bajaban en los
barrios pudientes del norte de la ciudad
de buenos aires- para recolectar el
material que por los altos niveles de
consumo estos barrios permitían
descartar un montón de material
reciclable y reutilizable estas personas
todo el día cirugía van para encontrar
estos materiales volver a sus barrios
con sus cargos con sus carros cargados
hasta el techo y bajar y venderlos a los
galponeros personas que compraban por
unas monedas estos materiales y que
luego lo revendían en la industria del
reciclado por un mejor valor
el tren blanco fue para mí un ejemplo de
supervivencia estas personas que no por
vocación sino por necesidad
revolvieron en la basura para poder
sobrevivir
mientras algunos se ayudan del país y
otros acaban supermercados y los que
tenían nuestra suerte tener un trabajo
lo hacíamos de lunes a lunes ellos se
estaban organizando se estaban
reinventando
creo en los procesos de transformación
de las cosas a través de las personas
pero sobre todo las personas a través de
las cosas a mí la basura me transformó
como siento que transformó la vida de
miles de personas
en el año 2003 tuve la suerte de
conseguir un trabajo en la universidad
de buenos aires cuando todavía el país
seguía tambaleándose
y empecé como administrativo en la
escuela de posgrado de la facultad de
agronomía y al tiempo que el área de
relaciones públicas que es el cargo que
todavía sigo ocupando entre las
múltiples actividades hace como 10 años
organicé una campaña de colecta de
tapitas y papel para la fundación
garraham
al tiempo me enteré que las cooperativas
de cartoneros se habían organizado y que
se podían llevar este material de
tapitas papeles pero además se podían
llevar
papeles cartones vidrios metales
plásticos wow
qué bueno voy a poder entregarle en mano
a todos esos cartoneros que antes
revolvió en la basura todo el material
limpio y seco que se genera en mi lugar
de trabajo
entonces los cartoneros son los que se
ocupan de llevar todos estos materiales
a los centros verdes donde lo dividen
por materiales lo enfadan lo condicionan
y lo venden a la industria el reciclado
al tener tanto volumen y enfardar logan
a un valor agregado de esta basura
consiguen mejores precios en el mercado
de los cartones nos habían organizado
tal manera que también cumplían un
servicio de higiene urbana en la ciudad
de buenos aires y que gracias a la ley
que ellos consiguieron que es la 992
estaban incorporados en un sistema
formal de trabajo con todo lo que esto
implica en lo legal en lo económico en
lo social para ellos
de a poco fui metiéndome cada vez más en
esta temática en esto de la inclusión
social en la gestión de ambiente y fui
estando cada vez más convencida de lo
que estaba haciendo pero desde el lugar
donde yo lo podía hacer no desde la
investigación encerrado en un
laboratorio investigando cuáles eran los
impactos de los materiales en el
ambiente esto es sumamente importante e
interesante pero no es mi competencia
tampoco soy una docente que estaba
enseñándole a los alumnos sobre las
investigaciones y los resultados de las
investigaciones
yo estaba aprendiendo a ser más urólogo
desde la gestión desde el hacer
cotidiano para lo cual no necesitaba más
capacidades que las que ya tenía y las
que fui adquiriendo con el correr del
tiempo con las cooperativas de
cartoneros
lo importante es que en la universidad
de buenos aires presentamos un proyecto
con algunas facultades que se fueron
acercando a conocer cuál era mi mi
proyecto de gua verde y lo presentamos
al rector de universidad buenos años
presentamos un proyecto del programa uva
verde
este proyecto fue aprobado por el
consejo superior y después designado la
secretaria de desarrollo de extensión y
bienestar estudiantil para su desarrollo
junto con este proyecto presentamos un
informe porque queríamos saber dónde
estábamos parados queríamos saber cómo
estaba hoy la universidad con respecto a
los residuos en lo personal siento que
fue mi tesis para recibirme basura voló
gas fue muchas informaciones que tenemos
que recabar y organizar para poder saber
que la universidad de buenos aires
tenemos 55 edificios que entre docentes
no docentes y alumnos somos 360 mil
personas las que pasamos todos los días
por esos edificios un poco más del 10%
de la población de la ciudad de buenos
aires imagínense 360 mil personas que
por semana generamos alrededor de 160
mil kilos de residuos un poco bastante
no y que de estos 160 mil kilos de
residuos que generamos hay un 40 por
ciento de residuos que es reciclable que
nada ciudad buenos aires hay 13
cooperativas de cartoneros que pueden
pasar a buscar los materiales con los
edificios de la universidad
pero lo más importante de todo es que si
toda la universidad de buenos aires
separa sus residuos en origen estaríamos
evitando que lleguen los rellenos
sanitarios 64 mil kilos de residuos por
semana además que podrían volver a las
manos de las cooperativas de cartoneros
para que ellos vendan entonces el
programa verde nos parece importante
incorporar y visibilizar el trabajo de
las cooperativas por eso los invitamos
también a dar charlas en las escuelas
secundarias de la universidad y en las
facultades para que nos cuenten sus
experiencias y que también ellos hablen
de los materiales que se reciclan que
son quienes más saben de la temática
también presentamos algunos proyectos de
extensión para que puedan desarrollar
desarrollar materiales o productos a
partir de materiales reciclados estos
techos son hechos por cartoneros con
material reciclable para reciclar
también nos ayudamos a comercializar sus
proyectos sus productos en algunas
ferias o eventos de la universidad
la verdad es que bueno no voy a
mentirles y me encantaría a traerles acá
un proyecto exitoso y maravilloso pero
la verdad es que separar los residuos en
la universidad es una tarea muy
complicada y cambiar los hábitos de las
personas es un trabajo más complicado
aún aunque estoy segura de que es
posible
como en algún momento se colocaron
rampas en toda la universidad para que
las personas con discapacidad puedan
acceder a la universidad así también se
prohibió fumar en espacios públicos y
hoy se planifica la instalación de baños
mixtos creo imprescindible que en todos
los edificios de la universidad buenos
aires se separen los residuos en origen
la universidad de educa desde varios
aspectos formales e informales así como
educa en las aulas también educan los
pasillos no nos olvidemos de que la
universidad pública es sostenida por
millones de personas que sin obtener
ningún beneficio aportan para que
funciona gratuitamente por eso me parece
fundamental que todo lo que se haga en
la universidad de buenos aires o en
cualquier universidad pública vuelve a
transformado en algo útil para quienes
la sostienen
sí claro es una opción
que está en tus manos el que genera
residuos sos vos
si vos no lo separadas generas un
impacto negativo sobre el ambiente y
sobre todo las personas que viven en él
si separa estos residuos genera un
impacto positivo en lo económico en lo
social y en lo ambiental
la basura no existe
es sólo una percepción vos elegís qué
hacer con ella
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]